the point of switching from relational
language to graph theorem radical
languages really so that we can talk
about paths and connections so let's
look at the topic of graph connectivity
in general two vertices in a simple
graph or for that matter a directed
graph I said to be connected if and only
if there's a path between them in a
directed graph the path would have a
direction in a simple graph it pads
don't have direction so a is connected
to B if and only if B is connected to a
it's a symmetric relation so two
vertices are connected if and only if
there's a path between them that's
equivalent of course to saying if and
only if there's a walk between them we
include like zero paths in length zero
walk so every vertex is considered to be
connected to itself a whole graph is
said to be connected if all of its
vertex are connected to each other now
so every graph you can think of as
broken up into the mutually connected
pieces or sub graphs which are called
its connected components so let's look
at a simple example let's look at the
connections between MIT buildings where
we draw an edge between building 10 and
building 13 if there's a door between
them or a corridor between them so
there's a corridor between building 10
building 4 but not between building 10
and building 12 to get to 12 you have to
go through four that's the main building
numbers off the MIT infinite corridor
these campus course isn't connected to
anything so it's a single isolated
vertex and then there's the Medical
Center in E 17 and e 25 which are a
sequence of four buildings that are
connected as indicated but not connected
at all to East Campus or the infinite
corridor that is you have to go outside
to get from East Campus to the infinite
corridor from the infinite corridor to
the Medical Center unless you sneak
through the basement which and an other
restricted areas so this is one graph
it's not three graphs this is one graph
which has three parts and so it has
three connected components in general
the more connected components a graph
has the more broken up it is that's a
way to remember it the formal definition
of the connected
of a vertex V is simply all of the
vertices W that are connected to V and
if you look at these connected
components they've defined an
equivalence relation on the vertices of
course because a connected component is
a block of the equivalence relation it's
a block of the partition associated with
the equivalence relation another way to
say to define this the set of W that are
connected to V is simply it's taking the
image of V under the O greater than or
equal to zero walk relation East are we
is our notation for the walk relation in
the graph whose edges are II including
walks of length zero so a graph is
connected then means it really has only
one connected component